it's a bit chaotic here it's really
noisy but behind me
27 migrants were just dropped off
they came again in a charter bus today
on friday the second day of migrants
being released
from the tent encampment in matamoros
mexico
i'm here in bronzeville texas at the bus
stop today
25 more we're just dropped off and we
understand three more batches
are to come behind me is juana elisabeth
herrera for three weeks she came from
honduras she has a three-year-old and
she has a
one-year eight-month-old and her
seven-year-old
daughter lives in greeley colorado where
she's going too
now all the migrants behind me have been
screened for coronavirus
so they're staying behind that red line
to make sure that they don't catch
anything from anyone like the media
and they could be here for as long as 12
hours until they
catch their transportation to wherever
they're going to go
and they have promised that they will
appear for what's called a notice to
appear
wherever an immigration court hearing
they have is
scheduled in whatever city that they're
going to i had the opportunity today to
speak to a number of families as i did
yesterday and i'll express
extreme relief at being released i'll
express
thankfulness to the various non-profit
organizations that have helped them
along the way we're excited to see our
friends that have been in the encampment
so long
but it's you know it's a little
bittersweet for us because
we won't see them again you know so this
is kind of a
final thing for us so so happy for them
but
it's sad too it's you know it's hard to
explain
it's hard to believe that this is
happening it's such an emotional moment
for every single one of them just seeing
them for so long
suffering so much hopeful and yet uh
desperate and now it happened you know
it's
the doors open wide and
they're walking through the head up high
through the main door you know in
brownsville texas for border report.com
i'm sandra sanchez